uh how did you first develop that throw
so for people um
it's called ippon senagi which means
your right hand goes under their like
armpit area
and that that's like a vice that
connects you to them yeah and then they
get go on for the ride yep the
interesting thing with the standing one
is
as opposed to drop sanagi version
the drops in ag you kind of
drop under them and because there's the
vice they're like pulled
pulled under and like over yeah uh with
the standing one i suppose there's some
similar physics but you're kind of
loading them onto your hip
and so they're in the air
while you're standing still
there's there's a there's a sense in
which they're
like you're lifting them above
where they started yes
that's how you get the really big air
yeah if obviously if
um
if everything is right so how did you
first develop that how did you first i
first learned just learning like the
very basics of the throw you know foot
placement all that kind of stuff and
then
you know like anything the basics are
nice
um but once you get good at the basics
it's it's very easy to stop but it gives
you a good like fundamental platform to
learn off of and
to expand off of
and then i expanded when i first started
watching koga the new wind right because
he's the one that first like
introduced that split hip style sayanagi
that i do
um once i
learned that one i built
about eight different variations of sayo
off that one start position
that way i could regardless of your
defense i had an answer for a throw so
why that one though why can you uh can
you describe love to me travis stevens
why did you fall in love with that throw
in particular
um it
it was really a sense of
you know one of my shortcomings as a kid
like i hate
leg day in the gym i hate it with a
passion i
if you ask me to do a squat i'll i'll
get it done
but i will and moan every step of
the way i hate it i remember one time i
was at the gym with my trainer and he
goes okay we're gonna do front squats
and i want you to put 225 on the bar and
i was like i can't do that
and he was like what do you mean you
can't do that and i go
i i physically i can't do that and he
was like
are you serious and i go yeah so he's he
didn't believe me we put 225 on the bar
and i bottomed out
and then he was like okay let's go down
to 185 and i was like i can't do that i
just it's not happening you probably
couldn't strength wise you just refused
i just mentally i cannot wrap my head
around like this ain't happening i'm not
doing it so i ended up your man like
principal
95 pounds on the bar i got you with a
front squat no problem by the way body
weight squats are rough too
psychologically so yeah i just when it
comes to my legs like
i want no part of like
leg pressing single leg squat split
squat any of that no part of it so you
think like the more traditional variants
of saying i can require you to have that
leg strength yeah that mass like when
you watch japanese judo players like
their thighs and their hips they're
thick
they got a lot of power there so you're
almost like always dropping a little bit
into a squat position for mine never no
no no not you sorry for the the
traditional ones yeah and so the split
hip
the split hip actually allows me to keep
my legs straight yeah and the farther i
split my legs the lower my center of
gravity goes now i don't need my legs
yeah
perfect love it let's do it so that's
the way you were thinking about it okay
yeah um but it's uh you know the
interesting thing about it is because
you know as i mentioned to you i've
gotten to judo after first watching you
in the uh olympics and then
watching koga as well and so you start
imitating the people you first see
and then you take it to judo coaches and
they're like no no no that's the wrong
way to do it
and it happens all the time it drives me
nuts drives me nuts i was in poland one
time
teaching a camp
and i had two coaches
anti-coaching
telling their kids not to do sayo the
way i do it because it never works yeah
it's crazy how do you have the fortitude
and the guts to just go on with a throw
that's not traditional that a variant
that's not traditional
if you think about it
you know from a very
basic like root of it
there's a philosophy and a mentality of
judo of how the throws work
right there's a mechanical structure
there of like
this makes sense
if i follow that principle i can do
anything i want
nothing else matters as long as we
follow those core principles so in the
early days even
even then you were able to think on your
own yeah and i was able to develop
a pattern for my foot placement
based on my opponent's height
because
the number one thing any judo coach will
tell you is you need your center of
gravity below yours
well now i now i know exactly where to
put my feet because
the shorter you are the bigger the split
because the lower i need to get the
taller you are the less of a split i
need
you